cette partie-ci appartient aux étoiles
[Musique]
Michaud peut ouvrir toutes les portes au
Siège de l'Organisation des Nations
Unies à des montres que j'ai accès à
tout
l'assemblée générale donc on peut
rentrer
[Musique]
le Conseil de sécurité c'est que ça se
passe
il est au cœur des enjeux de l'heure
d'un dernier années ça a pris un emprise
considérable de mon temps chaque jour
chaque jour je suis engagé avec nos
opérations en Ukraine
le secrétaire général adjoint et
responsable de la sécurité pour toutes
les opérations de l'ONU dont la
livraison d'une cinquantaine de
milliards de dollars par année en aide
humanitaire donc on a plus de crises qui
arrivent de façon plus rapide et de
façon simultanée c'est vraiment le gros
changement que j'ai observé depuis 2019
c'est que
200 millions de personnes auront besoin
de l'aide de l'ONU cette année un défi
exacerbé par les guerres en Ukraine et
en Éthiopie les crises au soudain et en
somalies et les tremblements terre du
début février en Turquie et en Syrie il
y a tellement de gens qui sont dans le
besoin qu'on se doit de prendre des
risques parce qu'on parle vraiment de
prendre des risques pour sauver des vies
à toutes les jours et après
il y a des endroits comme l'Afghanistan
et la Syrie où il n'y a pas de force de
l'Otan et aucune troupe occidentale dans
ces endroits on laisse l'ONU s'occuper
des gens qui bien franchement autrement
été abandonnés
et les opérations humanitaires se
multiplient aux quatre coins du monde le
budget des services de sécurité de l'ONU
stagne et les équipes tentent d'en faire
plus avec moins par exemple on va
déployer en Turquie une personne qui est
en Somalie alors qu'en Somalie on a une
crise qui se passe la crise c'est notre
quotidien et on ne peut pas nous-mêmes
être en crise pour répondre aux crises
donc on a besoin d'avoir une certaine
sérénité dans la gestion de la crise
le département de sécurité de l'ONU
dispose d'un budget annuel de 300
millions de dollars américains un
montant insuffisant selon l'agence qui
coordonne les opérations humanitaires de
l'ONU le premier critère fondamental
pour livrer de l'aide humanitaire
n'importe où dans le monde n'ont pas
seulement pour l'ONU mais aussi pour les
organisations non gouvernementales c'est
la sécurité
pour moi la plus grande préoccupation
c'est que les Nations Unies vont pas
être capables de livrer l'aide
humanitaire là où les populations en en
ont besoin et donc on va se retrouver
dans des bons coeurs dans des bâtiments
fortifiés on va pas sortir
[Musique]
j'ai le Michaud vient de lancer une
campagne de financement auprès de pays
donateurs pour se doter d'une équipe
d'intervention rapide une première étape
pour mieux protéger le personnel le
temps que ça prend
pour bâtir le support en matière de
sécurité c'est du temps qui est perdu
pour livrer les services à la population
canadien originaire du Nouveau-Brunswick
ancien au gradé de la GRC Gilles Michaud
aimerais kotawa contribue une dizaine de
millions à son projet un temps canadien
je me suis viré vers le Canada je crois
que le Canada aura une opportunité ici à
avoir un impact majeur en investissant
peu
au sein de mon département le
gouvernement fédéral affirme étudié la
demande de Gilles Michaud pendant ce
temps l'ONU continue à œuvrer dans les
coins des plus dangereux du monde il y a
des millions et des millions de
personnes qui souffrent à tous les jours
qui savent pas si demain matin il va en
voir la nourriture qui va avoir se
déplacer à nouveau mais de le voir sur
le terrain d'engager avec eux des
écouter et de voir ce qui ce qu'il
demande qui sont vraiment des demandes
de base ça m'a fait toujours ce que tu
vois c'est les Nations unies à l'oeuvre
car au-delà de veiller à la protection
des édifices de l'ONU j'ai le Michaud
cherche avant tout assurer la sécurité
de son personnel et des populations en
danger ici Daniel Leblanc Radio-Canada
New York
[Musique]